[Música]
Hablamos ahora de economía aquí en
directo América edición nocturna me
acompaña en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de las novedades los debates
que tuvieron lugar en la jornada de hoy
en el foro económico mundial de davos en
Suiza bueno sin duda alguna lo que marcó
la agenda fue el cambio climático la
guerra en Ucrania y por supuesto esta
reunión entre Estados Unidos y China la
secretaria del tesoro de Estados Unidos
acordó con el Vice Primer Ministro chino
Ninja mejorar la comunicación sobre
temas climáticos y financieros ambas
partes se acordaron mejorar la
cooperación bilateral y multilateral en
materia de financiación de la lucha
contra el cambio climático también habló
el secretario general de la Organización
de Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez
afirmó que el mundo se encuentra en un
estado lamentable durante su
intervención el máximo responsable de la
ONU afirmó que la creciente división
geopolítica como consecuencia de la
guerra en Ucrania está destruyendo los
esfuerzos por para enfrentar problemas
como la inflación con la llegada a davos
también de la activista greta thunberg
que se reunirá el jueves con el director
ejecutivo de la agencia internacional de
energía el cambio climático seguirá
siendo el centro de atención y por
supuesto hubo presencia de América
Latina en este importante encuentro
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
tildó de fracaso absoluto la guerra
contra el narcotráfico durante una
reunión con otros presidentes como el de
Ecuador y Costa Rica También estuvo
presente el Ministerio de Hacienda el
ministro de hacienda de Brasil y el
vicepresidente de República Dominicana
también propuso Petro que los países
lleven a cero el consumo de las energías
no renovables como una forma de combatir
el cambio climático escuchemos parte de
su intervención
desde hace unos 50 años esa política es
criminalizarla la guerra contra las
drogas
si uno hace un balance en América toda
sobre qué pasó con esos 50 años uno no
podría decir más que es un absoluto
total fracaso
y nos vamos ahora a Estados Unidos
porque en este país detuvieron al
fundador de otro exchange de
criptomonedas por infringir las leyes de
blanqueo de capital de ese país
norteamericano Qué pasó Bueno ese país
acusó a anatoli leco di mop un ciudadano
Ruso y también residente en China por
blanqueo de capitales a través de la
plataforma de compra y venta de
criptoactivos que el mismo fundó donde
supuestamente ocultaban apuestas
ilegales y negocios de drogas por valor
de más de 700 millones de dólares el
hombre fue detenido en Miami y hace un
tiempo publicó en un chat interno que
los usuarios de bitslato eran conocidos
por ser delincuentes hoy se conoció que
otra empresa de este sector de
criptoactivos Génesis global capital
prepara sus documentos para declararse
en bancarrota esto según bloomberg y
pasamos ahora a hablar de el euro que
recobró fuerza frente al dólar
estadounidense todo esto después de los
datos publicados por Estados Unidos y
también algunos comentarios por parte
del Banco Central europeo bueno la
moneda europea llegó a un máximo de
nueve meses en positivo se cambió por
1,8 dólares esto porque se conoció que
los precios de producción subieron en
Estados Unidos en diciembre en 6,2%
interanual y las ventas minoristas
cayeron en diciembre un uno coma uno por
ciento más de lo previsto también por
los comentarios de un miembro del
Consejo del gobierno del gobierno del
Banco Central europeo que apuntó a
varias subidas de más de 50 puntos
básicos de los tipos de interés en el
bloque y hablemos ahora de Google y de
Microsoft se adentran en una dura
batalla por la Inteligencia artificial
Ahí está un futuro empresarial ahí bueno
el asunto así Google considera que la
Inteligencia artificial generativa O sea
la basada en aprendizaje automático y
que es capaz de mantener conversaciones
o resolver dudas será el nuevo campo de
batalla de las empresas tecnológicas por
su parte Microsoft considera que la
aplicación de el chat gpt donde ya
invirtió mil millones de dólares será
capaz de la productividad en el trabajo
y las relaciones con los usuarios el
lanzamiento de esta tecnología causó un
gran furor en redes sociales Porque tan
solo los primeros cinco días logró más
de un millón de suscriptores el debate
está porque se especula sobre la
posibilidad de que estas nuevas
herramientas como el chat gpt que tiene
la capacidad de terminar con los modelos
actuales de producción pueda sustituir
en un futuro a los buscadores de
gigantes como Google Jorge indicadores
bueno empezamos con Estados Unidos ahí
se borraron las ganancias tras los malos
datos macroeconómicos el dólar se
debilitó y los rendimientos del tesoro
cayeron en Europa las acciones marcaron
su racha de ganancias más larga desde
noviembre de 2021 esto impulsadas por
buenos beneficios y el optimismo sobre
la recuperación económica de China que
elevó los valores de lujo y en América
Latina un mal día para el índice s&p
merval que cerró con una bajada del
9,73% tras siete jornadas consecutivas
en positivo Muchas gracias Jorge por
esta actualización continuación en
directo América damos paso al debate
[Música]